horton tucker over to davis
goes quickly against metoo
little jump hook automatic
[Applause]
davis
on the post up iso on the wing
[Music]
turns on metoo
help came a little late from lane it
went in off glass
team foul hey they're gonna go to the
free throw line and shoot some now well
here you see anthony davis what frank
vogel's trying to do is he's trying and
that's davey on spot that's where he's
hit his two threes here tonight
westbrook downhill over lynn for the
basket and here they come the lakers
down by two pulls it back out to monk
who's had the hot hand from downtown
davis thought about it quicksit dribble
middy ties the game at 72.
[Applause]
westbrook in the front court in a hurry
fakes the handoff inside davis with the
punch
i mean the reality of that is that
they've been there done that and they're
gonna trying to teach him the shots and
where he wants him to pick his spots and
how to pick the momentum of the game up
carmelo anthony
said he's too little
one point
and the momentum that the lakers have
picked up and the kings have had no ant
[Applause]
rondo gets by king high off glass for
the layup
third five turnovers that ended up in
eight points for the lakers and that's
what really helped mount that comeback
rondo on the drive gets the layup to go
you know with that flat screen set by
davis
broken up nicely by the kings davis
retrieves it
step back mid-range jumper pure
ellington with six on the shot glock
over to westbrook
westbrook got downhill
full jelly
fantastic description katie when you
think about the first half versus what
we've seen in the second half
the first half feels like a week ago
already as dwight howard punches one
home
[Applause]
long drives baseline they faked the
hammer play
called his own number took out his
do-it-yourself kit and scored the bucket
you know still finding his leadership
voice
this is one of those
hard learned lessons
as monk
the head of this franchise the the
franchise player you you've paid him you
put all of your trust and money in here
see this is what you can't let happen